[Music]
so this being the final season when you
sat down for season one had this awesome
vision of servant do you feel like where
the show's ending is where you had a
vision or was there a lot of like twists
and turns along the way to where it
ended up you know I've never done this
format so it's a long it's a long format
so you have the advantage of two things
one that you get to really learn the
characters uh which is the great benefit
of this format you know whereas whereas
in a movie you drive driving drive and
driving right and you have to do
character work as fast as you can well
here you languish you get really you
luxuriate in the characters and what
that gives you is the opportunity to let
the characters tell you where should the
story go and so I we got we had that
opportunity both at the end of the first
season where then we learned something
but then the ironically the pandemic
gave me the opportunity that we couldn't
leave the house and I just went huh
well I know I want this to happen I know
I want that to happen I just put up on
the board every day walk by it and added
another thing and another thing and
another thing and then you saw the
movement of the story that you guys will
see awesome man great answer and thanks
for giving us a great show thanks